Welcome to a three
lecture series
on both fungi
and viruses and
those lecture
series will explore
or at least introduce
fungi and viruses
as microorganisms.
This should lay the
groundwork for many
of the microbiology
lectures that will come
in your curriculum.
In this lecture we're
going to cover these
objectives. We're
going to try to
compare and contrast
fungal cells with other
cells, whether it's
microbial cells or
human cells. We're
gonna talk about the
major types and
characteristics of fungi.
We're gonna outline the
difference between
yeast and mold.
We're gonna define the
term fungal dimorphism.
We're also gonna
recognize the
relationship between
the environment
and the acquisition
of fungal
infection, which
is very important,
especially when
recognizing and trying
to identify specific
fungal infections.
Now we're going to
talk a little bit
about antifungal
agents, and of course,
once you guys get to
pharmacology, you'll
be exploring that
into more detail.
So fungi are considered
eukaryotic cells
because they do have
a nuclei, although
they have some
characteristics of
both eukaryotic and
prokaryotic cells.
But they are
eukaryotic, again,
because they have
membrane-bound
organelles, they are
mostly free living.
They've evolved alongside
animal cells, but
they are a separate
phylum of a separate
category. Fungi are
not mobile. They only
have flagella. They
are unable to move.
They have a cell
wall like most cells,
of course, except
animal cells, and
they typically do not
undergo photosynthesis
like bacteria and
plants and algae.
Most fungi are very
beneficial and they're
essential almost to our
life on this planet.
They are saprophytes,
they are decomposers
that constantly turn
over organic matter
into inorganic matter
and make life possible.
In this table it
outlines the difference
between bacteria,
fungi and viruses. It's
important to know these
distinctions and you
can see there's
distinctions in size. So
of course fungi are
larger typically than
bacteria and of course
larger than viruses.
Fungi and
bacteria are cells
but you know
viruses are not
cellular and
they're non-living.
Fungi has DNA just
like all living things
and bacteria have
DNA as a genetic
material with viruses
it can be DNA or RNA.
The ribosomes of fungi
are the ADS if you
recall because they
are eukaryotic unlike
the bacteria which
is 70S and they of
course they have
membrane body organelles
and none of this
stuff is applicable
for viruses because
they're not settler.
They have a cell
wall, like we talked
about, just like
bacteria and just like
plants, but the cell
wall of fungi is
different in its
composition from bacteria.
It's made out of
a chitin material
called chitin. It's a
sugary material, but
it's a very tough
material. A combination
of chitin and a
sugar called glucan.
Chitin is also found,
just to give you
an idea, in shellfish.
So if you look
at a crab, that
shell of a crab is
actually made out
of chitin so that's
pretty false you
know tough material.
Viruses do not
have cell walls
they may have an
outer layer called an
envelope which is
phospholipid in nature and
viruses enclose their
genetic material in a
protein cover called
a capsid. We'll talk
about viral structure
more as we move into
this three lectures
and it was talked about
fungi are not motile
some bacteria do of
course viruses are not
and they replicate by
by mitoses just like
our cells but they
also have a distinctive
replication mode called
budding which we
will discuss which is
something you don't
see in other organisms
and you know as you
know by now bacteria do
not divide by mitoses
or budding they divide
by binary fission
viruses replicate within
cells They require
a host to replicate.
The cell membrane of
fungi, just like the
cell membrane of
bacteria and many living
things, is predominantly
phospholipid, but
instead of having
cholesterol which stabilizes
the membrane, they
have a modification
of cholesterol.
It's still a steroid
molecule, but it's called
argosterol, and that's
important because it
is unique to fungi
and allows us to target
that for therapy.
fungi are pretty much
everywhere everywhere
you look on this planet
you'll you'll find
fungi they are by
definition ubiquitous they
also can be both unicellular
and multicellular
and what do i mean
by that so some
organisms can be unicellular
some words can be
multi but what i'm
referring to here is the
same fungal cell or the
same the same fungal
species can be both
uni and multi depending
on the environmental
conditions and that's
referred to as dimorphism
which is a very
important term and it's
actually a unique term
for fungi and so think
of it that way just
to kind of give you
an analogy think about
us as humans we are by
definition multicellular
organism but imagine
if each one of our
cells can go on by itself
so let's say it can
exist as unicellular
and spread through the
planet let's say and
then at some time they
can also come back
together and become
multi so imagine that
ability of being becoming
a multicellular organisms
and then becoming
a unicellular the same
multicellular organisms
spread their cells
and then come back
together we obviously
cannot do that but fungi
can and it's a really
very interesting way
usually they do that
in response to food so
when food is scarce
fungi become unicellular
and they spread out
and seek out food and
once they do find it
then they replicate
the much higher rate by
budding or mitosis and
then they become
multicellular okay unicellular
fungi are usually
referred to as yeast
while multicellular
fungi we'll talk about
that more are usually
the molds and the
mushrooms fungi by the
way like we said they're
again they're very
very beneficial but
sometimes they can cause
disease most of the
disease they cause
actually to plant pathogen
they can do they can
be very notorious in in
growing on plants and
causing crop disease
and devastating crops
and so on if you
guys ever heard of
the Irish blight which
resulted in the
migration of many Irish
people back in the turn
of the century that
was due to a fungi
that infected potato
plants, referred to
as the potato blight.
Fungi are also
responsible for
fermentation things
like making bread,
so the yeast
that makes bread,
Saccharomyces
cerevisiae is a fungi,
the yeast of course
that makes beer,
the cheeses, a
lot of the cheeses
that we eat, blue
cheese, etc. and
some other kinds
are all from fungi.
Fungi also produce
antibiotics and they
do that to combat and
in competition with
bacteria, So the
penicillin, which was
one of the first
antibiotics discovered,
is made by the fungi
penicillium, which
is the one you see
in the figure there.
Also, they can make
immunosuppressive
drugs like cyclosporine.
Fungi are typically
aerobic, but they can
also be facultative
anaerobes in regard to the
metabolism. I don't
believe there are strict
anaerobic fungi. I
don't think those
exist, or at least we
haven't discovered them.
Fungi also tend
to be extremely
hardy. They're
very tough. They
can live just
about everywhere.
Again, going back to
that ubiquitous, but
you know, in the
last several years,
people discovered
fungi that are actually
growing in a nuclear
reactor. So they were
growing in uranium,
which is very
surprising because you
don't think a nuclear
reactor is a place
where life can exist.
But fungi actually was
living and
thriving in that.
there's been quite a
re-emergence of fungal
diseases throughout
the last 40 you know
four decades or 40
years predominantly due
to the fact that we have
more immunosuppressed
individuals or
immunocompromised
individuals because
you know medicine has
progressed and we were
able to extend the lives
of people with cancer
with HIV transplant
patients and so on and
so that also created
a niche for fungi to
grow also things like
using catheters surgery
and corticosteroid
treatment which also
induces a temporary
immunocompromised
condition also
promotes the
growth of fungi.
Fungal diseases are
referred to as mycoses
so that's the term
we use for that. In
regard to growth and
temperature we've talked
about this before but
fungi prefer more of
a room temperature so
more like a 20 degrees
celsius which is why
they don't really
like to grow inside
our body much because
our bio temperature
especially our blood
is 37 that's kind
of high for them and
that's why most
fungal infections in
humans tend to be on
the surface on the skin
because our skin
surface is more of a
temperature that's
similar to the environment
and that's why they
kind of stick to
the surfaces so to
speak that's also
partly also due to our
immune system because
our immune system
prevents them from
entering but they
really do not prefer our
environment so again
they mostly stick to
superficial and rarely
lead to systemic
disease but when they do
systemic fungal disease
is a very alarming
development and
typically has such a high
mortality and also is
usually indicative of
an underlying problem
typically the treatment
of fungi in general
is challenging because
fungi are eukaryotic
just like our cells
so selective toxicity
tends to be a challenge
and many of the
fungal treatments have
a lot of side effects
because they can also
target our cells.
One of the key things
about pathogenic fungi
is they have to be
union settler. That
is typically how they
invade the body and
also they are dimorphic
and so they are able
to do both and that's
across all fungal
species. So typically
when they do invade
the body they'll
usually go from the
multisettler to the union
settler and then they
end up invading the
body as It's possible
that sometimes within
the body to become
multicellular, you might
see like some hyphae,
it's not unusual, but
not very uncommon.
Again, they must
grow, to invade into
the blood, they must
grow at 37 degrees,
although usually not
ideal, but some of them
can, especially the
pathogenic ones. and
like we talked about a
little bit before fungi
are divided into mainly
two groups macroscopic
which is the ones
that we can see with
the ***** eye like
mushrooms that are
everywhere or microscopic
the microscopic fungi
can either be yeasts
and these are of course
the unicellular typically
shape-wise they're
spherical elliptical
and usually divide
by budding and the other
type of microscopic
fungi are mold and
mold usually grow in
structures tree like
structures called hyphae
which we'll look into
that basically they're
like tubular branching
of fungal cells and
usually those divide
by mitosis and so is
mushrooms and so typically
mold are multicellular
mushrooms are
multicellular yeasts are
unicellular and again
just to reiterate all
pathogenic fungi are
dimorphic so they switch
between the unicellular
and the multicellular
but typically
unicellular in the body.
These are hyphae and
this is what hyphae
look like and the
structures of hyphae and
how they look it's
very important a lot of
times especially on
to recognize bofungal
infections to interpret
laboratory results
and of course by default
many of your board
questions will be like
that especially when
it regards to fungal
infections they will
give you description
of the hyphae and
based on that you
should be able to narrow
down or at least help
narrow down the fungal
etiology and so hyphae
again like we talked
about they're
multicellular that are just
grow in links think
of them like chains
basically of square
looking cells right with
cell walls and so a
lot of times the hyphae
can have a septis you
can actually visually
see that by the
microscope separation
between the cells
and those are called
septated hyphae or they
don't have any distinction
between the cells
they just look smooth
and those are called
non-septated hyphae
when you have a
large mass of hyphae
altogether that's called
the mycelium and typically
when you get a
large mass of hyphae
like that or a mycelium
is when you can start
visually seeing that
fuzz on top of mold
so if you've ever
seen bread mold or
anytime you've seen
mold grow and it's like
fuzzy that fuzzy stuff
is a mycelium that's
a lot of hyphae um
there are two different
types of hyphae they're
vegetative hyphae
which is usually the
anchor themselves
and they absorb nutrients
so they're the ones
that are just in the
stuck to the surface
or the ground or
whatever that is and
they get the nutrients
and then you have the
aerial hyphae which
is the ones that are
protruding to the
outside into the air
and those the ones
that have spores on top
of them and these
spores can easily fly
and disseminate
and aerosolize and
basically end up
everywhere that's how they
project themselves so
the fungi is trying
to do by making these
structures really
is to disseminate
and spread to as many
places as possible
usually in response to
lack of nutrients
as nutrients become
scarce they become you
know they exude these
pores and they spread
everywhere you know
on the right side of
this figure you can
actually see subcated
and non-subcated
hyphae and sometimes
you can also look at
how the hyphae are
branching so sometimes
they're right angles
sometimes they're 45
degree angles okay
and those are also
important in identifying
different species
okay we mentioned in
the previous slide
how aerial hyvee
can can form spores
so let's talk a little
bit about fungal
spores because of
their importance
****** spores are different
guys from bacteria
in those spores although
they do have share
some similarity you
know both of them are
hardy to the environment
they can spread
easily they are kind of
a seed so to speak that
helps microorganisms
spread and germinate.
****** spores are,
I think they're
just as tough, maybe
bacterial spores
are probably
tougher, but ******
spores are also
pretty tough too.
So they can be
either derived
from ****** or
asexual production,
so either by budding or
mitosis or meiosis.
Asexual spores are
called conidia, so if
you see that terminology
that's what that
means and usually
those are produced by
pathogenic fungi and
those are usually just
like bacterial spores
in a sense they're
dormant resistant they
can highly disperse
and when they land
on green pasture they
germinate although keep
in mind the structure
of fungal spores
and bacterial spores
are different okay
the ontology which is
the development of an
individual organism
or anatomical from the
early stage to maturity
that that's what that
means how the fungal
spore develops over
time and the morphology
can be important in
identifying different
types of fungal spores
just to mention from
the previous slide
that the spores can be
infectious they can
also not only cause
infection but this a
lot of times they cause
allergies in people and
we'll talk about that
a type one
hypersensitivity to be more
accurate but how do we
acquire fungal infections
we just talked about
them now we you know
mostly from the
environment um you know we
inhale them or they
land on our body or some
other mechanism
typically fungi cannot
********* and most
organisms truly cannot
********* the intact skin
no microbe can go through
the air skin if it's
intact but if it
breaks if there's a
wound crack then they can
get through some of
the fungi that infect
us are like candida
species are actually part
of our normal flora
so they're endogenous
some i'm sorry not some
most fungal infections
are not contagious so
they don't transmit
from one person to the
other the exception
to that rule is the
fungal groups referred
to as dermatophytes
the dermatophyte is a
large group of fungal
diseases that basically
affect our skin things
like jock, itch,
athlete's food those are
notoriously contagious
again that's an
exception but most other
fungal infections are
not like histoplasmosis,
coxioides, blastomycosis
all these are
not contagious and
again like we talked
about they can cause
and there may be serious
type 1 hypersensitivity
reaction they can
also produce toxins I
will talk about those
and usually if there's
an outbreak of fungal
infections they usually
have special conditions
that are coming with
them either somebody
has disturbed an
ecosystem and resulted
in the spilling of
fungal spores or there's
a cluster of individuals
that are immunocompromised
and that's what
happens as a result.
Diagnoses of fungal
infection takes a
multiple approach
You have to have
laboratory identification,
of course, patient
history, location,
where they come
from, any predisposing
conditions, etc.
But let's focus a
little bit on the
laboratory diagnosis
of couple infections.
So, of course, you
combine the information,
especially with the
site of infection,
where that is
coming, and that
sometimes can clue us
to where we might be.
Typically, fungi
can be cultured,
just like you
culture bacteria.
unlike bacteria
who have many
different culture
media that we
talk about and
we use all fungal
microorganisms are
grown on one particular
agar the reason that
is the case because
this is so easy to
grow the agar is
referred to as Saborod's
agar which is simply
a type of potato
agar and fungi like
starch a lot and so
they grow perfectly fine
on that agar usually
to demonstrate
dimorphism You would
grow the plates, you'll
inoculate two plates,
and you'll put one
at like 20 to 30
degrees Celsius, then
one at 37, and watch
the growth for both.
You can also examine
the fungi under a
microscope using either
KOH staining or HNA.
Of course, just like
we do with other
organisms, like with
bacteria, we do grab
stain, acid fast
stain. You can also use
DNA-based detection
methods like PCR,
fluorescent in-situ
hybridization, serology.
also works on the right
side here i have a
table for you to show
you key fungal structures
that you see in
microscopic examination
make sure you look
through that because
it's important it
outlines to you like which
yeast for example
have capsules that's
crypto and cryptos is
the only fungal with
capsules you can easily
identify that you can
see which yeast
have hyphae that are
subdated which ones are
not subdated and so this
type of information
is very important in
in singling out, at
least narrowing down
the type of fungal
disease we're looking at.
Again, as we progress
through the curriculum,
more and more about
this information will
come. And apparently,
you know, on the
level one boards, a
significant number of
questions do cover fungal
infections. So this
slide is just to share
with you, show you a
little bit different
colonial morphology of
fungi i mean nothing
that i expect you to
know that or be able
to recognize but just
like bacteria there's
fungi also can grow
different ways and a
laboratory technician
who's an expert in
looking at this can tell
sometimes the um the
genus of the fungi from
looking at the colonial
morphology so this
could add to the
information um these are
some fungal epidemics
that have occurred
throughout time and what
I want you to notice
about this is how in
every single time there
was some disruption
to the environment so
as we talked about
before disruptions the
environment cause a cluster
of a fungal infection
as you can see here
and I don't mean I
don't have to read
that for you but you
could tell that like
for example sometimes
earthquakes can result
in increased coxioides
construction near
hospitals increased
aspergolus infections
tree cuttings
to be associated
with histoplasmosis
and there are key
endemic regions you
know like histoplasmosis
endemic in the higher
river valley coxiodes
in the southwest of
the united states
and so knowing these
is important sometimes
in zooming in and
focusing on at least in
eliminating what the
possibilities for the
etiology is so make
sure you you focus on it
so these are different
types of mycoses
classified by usually
location so we have
superficial mycoses
typically microbes that
infect our skin
especially the epidermis
specifically and then we
have cutaneous mycoses
and here we're actually
involving the organ
completely so not
just the epidermis but
not sorry not just
the epidermis but can
also be the dermis
subcutaneous mycoses so
now we're getting into
the subcutaneous layers
and so they're
again these are more
invasive mycoses and
then of course we have
these systemic mycoses
where the fungal
infection spread throughout
the body and those
are the most serious
and then we have a
category of mycoses
referred to as opportunistic
mycoses and there
will be a full lecture
about the subject next
year in the program
but that basically
talks about the
different types of
mycoses involved with
opportunistic infections,
mainly infections that
result from a state
of immunocompromised.
So let's talk about
superficial and
cutaneous mycosis.
These are probably the
most common of all
communicable diseases.
They are just really
widespread. Most
people have some sort
of superficial cutaneous
mycosis at least
one time in their
life, if not more.
They're mainly caused by
malassezia species
the dermatophytes or
candida which is part
of our normal flora
you can see here a
picture of patyrus
vesicolor which is a
superficial mycoses
the dermatophytes as
we talked about they're
usually inhibited by
our own body temperature
so they very rarely
become invasive
but they are but they
so they stay on the
surface but they can
cause you know a variety
of different nuisance
diseases you can call
them but you know
but they still affect
people different
types like microsporum
trichophyton epidermophyton
on the right side
at the bottom figure
shows ringworm which is
a which is a fungal
infection caused by
trichophyton rubrum
these infections are very
persistent they are
very troublesome for
people they resist
treatment and even if you
treat them and go away
they'll come back.
The dermatophytes are
divided into geophilic,
zoophilic and
anthrophilic and that's
depending on the origin.
So geophilic dermatophytes
originate from the
soil. Example of
that would be Microspodium,
Microsporum gypsum
and usually those
result they're acute
they're quick and they
resolve quickly and rarely
reoccur so those are
really minor also
the zoophilic we acquire
from animals like
microsporum canis same
thing just like the
geophilic they're acute
resolve quickly rare
you know you don't see
them that often but
then you have the
anthrophilic type of
dermatophytes which we
acquire from other humans
which is you know
that's why they're very
infectious like trichophyton
brudrum we talked
about it a second ago
these are chronic take
a long time to treat
even when they leave
they occur frequently
and they're really
quite a nuisance and
sometimes they don't even
respond to treatment
let's talk about a
subcutaneous mycoses so
again those truly reside
in the soil or
vegetation there again
they're not that common
um a cut from uh let's
say a thorn or something
basically allows
the fungi to enter into
the subcutaneous layer
uh usually they either
becomes an ulcer
or a granulomatous nodule
and usually expands
slowly. It's not
typically invasive. It
gets just confined to
the subcutaneous layer.
A classic example
of that is
sporochicosis,
which is sometimes
referred to as
rosebud disease.
And usually
this is due to
the fungi,
Sporothrix shinky.
And so typically
that happens when
somebody's working
in the garden, and of
course roses
basically have thorns.
The thorns allow
the prolific species
to enter into the
subcutaneous layer
and you get these
ulcerous regions.
Usually it's treated
with the fungal azole
referred to itraconazole
and we'll talk
about the antifungal
agents especially
azoles which are common
antifungal agents.
The systemic phycosis
group is a very serious
and dangerous fungal
infections usually
those tend to be soil
saprophytes so they live
in the soil so they're
mainly inhaled we
inhale them through our
lungs basically they
can be of the opportunistic
kind and so those
will happen in
immunocompromised individuals
with candida being the
most common pathogen
but also crypto
aspergulosis, mucor
mycoses, and the AIDS
-causing fungi, nomocystis
gervichii, which we'll
discuss that later.
But then we also have
the endemic fungi,
and the endemic
fungi typically can
cause systemic mycoses
even in generally
healthy populations,
but only in a
limited amount of
individuals so we're
not sure why that
happens but examples
of that would be
coccidioidomycosis,
hystoplasmosis,
and blastomycosis
and we'll talk
about these.
I've included this slide
for you to highlight
how sometimes a fungi
that is typically
does not cause disease
can cause disease
because of the opportunity
that's provided.
So in September 2011
there's an article
here in El Xavier American
Journal of Pathology
shows how there
was a contaminated
epidural injections of
a steroid that actually
was contaminated with
this fungi called
Exoronium rostratum
and basically 13,000
patients were exposed
to this phone call and
notice you know Most
of them were okay, but
750 of those developed
illness and actually
end up with 63 deaths.
You can see how this
highlights how a deduction
of a microorganism
can happen, something
like a ******.
And we still
understand why very few
people get disease
and why most don't,
but just wanted
to show you that.
This is just an
informative slide
showing you just
a breakdown of
the different
pathogenic fungi.
it's not all inclusive
but it has a lot
of them so you can see
the superficial what
they're combined to the
dermis and epidermis
or the subcutaneous
ones and different
pathogens and the
systemic ones and
locations of those
so look at this table
because it really organizes
a lot of those and
it's really very
concise but it gives
you a lot of information
that can help you
Fungi, like many
microbes, produce
many different
virulence factors.
For example, they're
able to switch
genes from metabolic
processes, so
can adapt to different
requirements.
They can produce
adhesions,
which allow them to bind.
They have some
of them produce a
variety of enzymes
like proteases,
catalase, nucleases
that can digest
and acquire nutrients
from our body.
Some of them can
produce products that
can evade phagocytosis,
for example the
sugar glucan on the
surface can do that.
Also something
like a ****** like
cryptococci, which
has capsules, can help
it evade phagocytosis
and they can
also produce biofilms,
which makes them
highly resistant
to many different
conditions in the body.
On top of causing
direct disease, fungi
can also cause type
1 hypersensitivities
simply by the amount
of particles and the
spores they can produce
and emit into the
air, especially if
you're talking about
an enclosed space
like black mold, etc.
And so that's
usually referred to
sometimes as sick
building syndrome.
In addition to that,
which can be a serious
issue and that has
to be mitigated and
sometimes at a cost,
at a great cost at a
building, some fungi
can produce a lot
of toxins which are
referred to as mycotoxins,
of course mushrooms
produce tons of
different toxins as
you already might know
you know some of them
example would that
be like aflatoxin or
alpha amenitin aflatoxin
causes actually dna
damage it reacts
with guanine residues
and cause them to
and basically results
in deep purination
and alpha amenitin
which we talked about
before actually blocks
rna polymerase too,
and prevents
our cells from
transcribing and
making proteins.
Again, both aflatoxin
and alpha-manitin
are extremely toxic
products from fungi.
The last few
slides, we're going
to explore
antifungal agents.
Now, there will be, of
course, pharmacology
-specific lectures
about antifungal agents
where you guys will explore
in a lot more detail
the mechanism of
reaction of your these
fungi, but at least this
gives you kind of an
introduction to that
and gives you some head
up into some of these,
you know, difficult
subjects. The pharmacology
of these agents,
but don't
forget these are
extremely important
subjects as a
physician and also
on your board.
So let's talk about
different types of
antifungal agents and the
different classifications
they fall on so of
course a very common
antifungal agents are
called the pollines
and the pollines and
the classic polline
is amphotericin b
amphotericin b is probably
one of the very strong
antifungal agent
has a broad spectrum
of activity a lot of
times utilized in
systemic fungal infections
so you'll see that
quite commonly actually
and and all the
pollines basically work
the same way which
they bound bind the
ergosterol the ergosterol
if you remember from
this lecture we talked
about a little bit
earlier it replaces
the cholesterol in the
membranes of fungi
and provides the cell
membrane with stabilization
so because it's
different from our
from cholesterol which
is found in our membranes
these substances
can't target the
ergosterol and disturb
the cell membranes of
fungi nystatin is also
another polyene and
it's a topical It's
extremely toxic to be
used intravenously,
for example, or anything
else than topical.
Flu cytosine is another
example of an antifungal
agent. This one
does not target the
astrol. It's actually
a permidene analog. It
actually looks like
cytosine and so it basically
disrupts DNA replication
of the fungi.
Another large group
of antifungal agents
referred to as the
azoles. the azoles all
work by inhibiting
ergosterol synthesis.
Now remember this
mechanism, inhibition of
ergosterol synthesis,
is different from
simply binding ergosterol,
so be aware that
binding the substance
and preventing it
from functioning is
different from preventing
the actual make of
that substance. So
those are key differences
to note there.
The azoles are, you
know, again very
important antifungal
substances. Sometimes
they're combined
with amphotericin B
for treatment, so
ketoconazole is an
example, nitraconazole,
fluconazole,
myconazole, which is
used topically a lot.
That's the, for example,
lotramine, the one
on the side here,
clodotrimazole, is
also a type of isole,
the one I'm showing on
the top, which is used
for treatment of,
like, jock itch, okay?
Grisofulvin is an
antifungal agent specially
used for dermatophytes.
It actually
disrupts microtubules
formation, so basically
disrupts the cytoskeleton.
I know you've
taken some of this
information with Dr.
Camarada, so this
should tie into that.
So this is another
important
antifungal agent.
And a recently
discovered, I wouldn't say
recent, like maybe in
the last few years, but
terbinoffin is a pretty
important drug it
inhibits ergostatal
synthesis too so it's
very similar to azoles
but seems to be very
effective against
dermatophytes which is why
people use it to
treat like fungal toe
infection athlete's food
ringworm and that in
basic terbinoffin goes
by the name Lamisil.
Terminophen is
the chemical
name, Lamisil is
the drug name.
The Echocandins is
also another group
of antifungal agents.
These are more
recently discovered,
even more recent than
Terminophen. Examples
though would be Capsufungin
and Micafungin and
those actually inhibit
glucan synthesis. So
remember glucan is
part of the cell wall
of fungi and so they
will have the fungi
cell wall production so
this would be similar
to let's say penicillin
in bacteria and the
mechanism of its action
they both inhibit
cell wall synthesis of
these microbes and of
course there's always
the development of
monoclonal antibodies to
fungal infection which
can be used and you know
more and more people
are looking into these
products one comment
comment about antifungal
agents guys is because
fungi are eukaryotic
like our cells and
there's always a
relative side effects
with many of these drugs
and some toxins they
involve which is why
they have to be used and
the person's different
reactions have to be
monitored carefully.
This slide is for
you to kind of show
you all the
different antifungal
targets that we
talked about so the
mechanisms like how
the azoles work,
how the terbinafene,
grezofulfine and how
they disrupt like
microtribules so it's kind
of a one place for
you to to look at that
from any more of a
instead of like a writing
it's more of a visual
representation to
help you understand
some of that material
so take the time to
look into it and see how
the different things
we just talked about
are involved so again
we at the end of this
lecture was basically
predominantly talking
about fungi we
introduced fungi and
talked about how they
are different from human
cells, our cells, and
other microbes like
bacteria and viruses.
We described the major
types and characteristics
of fungi, how
they are unique
basically as a microbial
agent. We talked about
difference between
yeast and mold, unicellular
versus multicellular
fungi. We defined
and described what
fungal dimorphism means
and how is that important
for survival. And
we talked about how
pathogenic fungi
by definition
are dimorphic in
nature we talked
about how
important it is to
taking the history of
the patient and looking
at the environment
where they have been
especially in with
like fungal respiratory
infection things like
histoplasmosis coxioides
etc and we ended
by talking and
discussing few
antifungal agents
and their mechanism
of action we
have not mentioned
this before but i know
all instructors
appreciate any feedback
from you guys on the
lectures with things
to improve things
that you like and so
if you ever have a
chance take the time I
would appreciate that
too for you to fill
out the lecture
feedback form thank you